36 years ago
and as far as i'm concerned my man
thinks i'm fat because i put on four
pounds so i gotta lose that full pound
yeah i mean because i i was four pound
heavier but as far as i'm concerned
if the women there and they're eating
they're eating they're eating they're
eating the age and they don't want to
help themselves leave them
why oh if not and you're married keep on
feeding them and just insure her buy all
the fattening foods going just kill her
off and just
die natural causes and claim the money
back
so okay so dude he should leave his wife
if she's not sleeping with him
if she gets bad what else what other
reasons what what you think if she can't
cook and she can't clean if she can't
listen right a woman needs to do all of
them things before you put a ring on her
thing and if the woman can't cook take
it home to mummy unless your mother
can't cook but no she needs to learn how
to cook i have to clean
and money
she needs to know how to sort out her
finances not like oh i've got a bill i'm
gonna go to daddy they need to sort of
because too many women
waste money and the women the men let
them waste the money and then they waste
all their money and then they want to go
and spend the men's well yeah women
women own seventy to eighty percent of
consumer debt even though they um they
make less money i bet 9 out of 10 women
got clothes in their in their in their
closet that still got tags on
yeah yeah that's what they have yeah you
see men don't do that
and women buy stuff that's fashionable
every time they want us we knew the
fashion member classic clothes that they
can wear this year next year the year
after but women just we may just waste
money you want a woman that's good with
money good in bed good with children can
cook
was it a chef in the kitchen
a [ __ ] in the bedroom a nanny
and a cleaner that woman's gotta be i
think there's about five different
things that you want in one woman
guys how did that how does that sound to
you let's just
get some feedback on what she said no no
it sounds good and
like look to be honest yeah i don't
think it's asking much
you know it's not it's not over and
beyond for those things
you know the basic things like you said
cooking cleaning just to
like and if you've been raised a certain
way you would have been you would have
known that naturally anyway do you know
what i mean and then you bring that into
a relationship to be honest the best
sort of raised women no matter what
country they're from are those that are
raised to be
traditional yeah exactly
so when they come into the relationship
oh can you cook it's a standard tour can
you roll a dumpling can you do fufu of
course you gotta take off your
fingernails for do you wear gloves to
season me come on there you go even even
on the black level even little things
like can you plat do you know what i
mean little things like that it's like
if they come with no it's like who
raised you type thing so by the time
you've got there you've got two three
four of the things naturally
already
because women seem to think it's like oh
because you know men want me because i
look good because i earn a lot of money
because i got a job i got a car i got
men don't want that they just want
someone
can i say something as a man sorry to
cut you off we do like women that look
good we like attractive women yeah
but if i'm going to be honest
most of us don't want a baddie i know it
looks that way i know things like social
media are ig and even some of the things
men say even
you know the whole sort of uh urban
hip-hop and even just hip-hop black
culture it's like we want baddies and
all that but realistically we don't want
we don't need to have a 10. most men
will tell you we'll take if you want to
rate a six
seven on the looks scale but all the
other like the boxes you said as long as
they've got those
we can go with that like we were saying
earlier
it it's not great to say but men do
they marry relationship if you want to
say the word settle in not the worst
context
we do so if she looks good on top bonus
and the sex should be you know a
standard thing yeah goodbye good sex and
to be honest as a woman don't you know
it's there's this whole notion that only
men like sex and i'm one of those people
but any any person i've had sex with in
my whole life whether it be a
relationship or even a one-night stand
as far as i'm concerned she wants me as
well it's not just i wanna just smash
her and she just let me i love it
do what i wanted to do you were the
footba yeah it's like an equal value
exchange but women treat it like it's
not exactly and and you know what's
interesting like some of the language we
have in society always takes
accountability off of the woman like for
example he knocked her up
or even almost or even even in the
church like the girls would always be
like oh i was so broken i was so lucky
no you're horny shut up
shut up and now you found god it's
convenient at 29.
matt
so um question people in the chat want
everyone to rate them on a scale of one
to ten rate themselves
oh wow
yeah
on a good day like i feel like i'm a
strong seven
seven
i give myself a six six
seven eight seven eight what are we
writing one to ten yeah what looks
like are we look okay
six seven six seven six
number four
no
oh
auntie okay i'm going to read super
chats
in my heyday i would have said i was a
knight i'm a fool oh a night in your
handbag yeah let me you got pecks let me
you see the pictures i think they were
on them
youtube oh we got a hundred dollar super
chat we're in class
y'all y'all okay
i'm trying to i'm trying to move into a
new apartment it's going to be big it's
going to be beautiful it
is tell them about the apartment how
nice is it tom
look at talking to the mic
skyline
top floor
views
from the six
nah from the one the e1 yo
special
special oh that's beautiful and the
color scheme the furniture
yo we gonna do a little mtv cribs kind
of thing yeah nice it's actually special
but we're only doing the apartment tour
on memberships so if you want to see it
you got to be in our second tier of
memberships which is the 10 tier i know
i'd share it with all of you
but i'm trying to get more members i'm
going to be honest
i'm just i'm just you know
if you if you want to see the full yeah
you got it you got it ten dollars it's
not that much okay anyways so thank you
to darvey jones for the 100 super chat
thank you auntie for top shelf content
you're getting so many supers today they
love you blowing up top shelf ain't good
right
top shelf in that like no that's good
that's good it's good that's good that's
good yeah i'm thinking nowadays you know
when you put things on the top shelf oh
no top notch think talk about it guys
we're going to work
we're going to work with annie and
auntie after we move and we're going to
like get her a little channel set up so
we're going to
you're going to get more content from
her so mgtow by logic
ladies on the couch are laughing but
auntie is trying to save your life your
pee is worthless if you don't share it
with a man who loves you get off your
horse you're not special
darkened flame ante you are fire preach
keep telling these secrets we need more
females with your commitment to honesty
ry morgan in the video yesterday you
talked about how men mature later so how
do you recommend they pursue women when
they are 20 to 21 because the women that
want to settle down are looking for
older men focus on purpose
um
yeah i mean
yeah i would just say as a guy like the
more you build yourself up the more
girls want you so if you get in the gym
and you make more money girls will come
mgtow by logic he might cheat on me even
but he might cheat on me even if i bang
him so i won't bang him just in case
chick logic is